the annual rate of inflation remains
steady at two-point-three percent last
month as lower fuel and flight costs
offset the fastest ride in food prices
in three years but consumers are feeling
the pinch us retail sales for March fell
for the third month in a row damn 1% on
the same month last year that
contributed to a decline in
like-for-like sales 2.7% during the
first quarter and that was the worst
three month figure since March 2011
British Retail Consortium chief
executive Helen Dickinson said as
pressure on prices continues to build
there is tighter squeeze on disposable
income I'm joined by the economist Lena
come over and retail expert Andrew
felstead who is a columnist at glad fly
well Lena inflation was steady in March
but is that largely because of the
timing of Easter it came earlier last
year there are some big price rises in
the offing precisely yes inflation which
saw a pause not a peak unfortunately I
think when we look at inflation figures
they're normally a lagging indicator of
growth a leading indicator of policy so
from the lens of the economy it's about
producer supply costs versus consumer
strengthened on this score at least
inflation has been very strong we've had
a rise of nearly half a percentage point
over the last two quarters and when you
look at the domestic prices so outside
the cost push inflation effects of
sterling and imported prices when you
look at sort of things like consumer
services inflation that's cleared the
bank of england's two percent target
over the last two months that when we
combine it with very low cycle low
unemployment rate very strong and secure
credit growth it shows an economy that's
very close to full capacity you look at
the Bank of England balance however and
they're clearly the fact that inflation
is running ahead of target it's probably
going to accelerate further in the
months ahead is going to call some
concern well that's right I'm in April
this month we've had a big rising
council tax right across the country
some water companies have put up their
bills I mean what point do you see CPI
rising above three percent I think that
is the likelihood yes next month we're
probably going to see the echo of the
civilization we saw this month because
of the timing of Easter as you say
the water rate hikes the electricity and
utility announced hikes are going to
come through but also the effects of air
fares so we will see inflation
accelerates rapidly towards three
percent in the months ahead with
something going to clear that I think by
the end of this year so Andrea we've
seen the biggest drop in consumer
spending in six years in the first three
months of the years that is the end of
the consumer boom it does look like the
consumer has taken appalls februari
march they definitely slowed down I
think there is one wild card and that's
the weather this lovely hot weather
we've had beginning of the season and
all the new fashions are coming in
schools are on holiday people will have
taken some time off that will to some
extent counteract that effect is there
much evidence of increased footfall in
the shops at the moment not at the
moment but it will come through I mean
we all shop very differently to how we
used if we don't go out at the beginning
of the season and buy a new summer
wardrobe or a new winter wardrobe when
the Sun shines we want new clothes and
we want them right now and I think this
will have a have a definitely an upward
effect on demand it's really striking
though about the inflation data today
that's rising food prices to which we
refer just now I mean supermarkets have
been cutting prices over the last few
years aggressive competition can they
just not carry on doing that their input
cost to hire their margins completely
shredded I think they will have to
increase to some extent and they will
increase in areas where the consumer
doesn't really notice it the the big
worry is that too much inflation comes
through and that drive consumers back to
the German discounted aldi and lidl so
it's a very delicate balance and
interestingly aldi and little with the
fur they raised milk and bread prices
towards the end of last year and that
all of the big four basically rub their
hands and said fantastic they that's a
sort of a key price sort of a product
that consumers really notice the price
of where they may not notice the price
so much as in other product and that's
where the increases will come through
Elena's really interesting consumer
services spending is holding up better
than retail sales is this because we've
reached peak stuff in the jargon
well it is it is an indicator that
things are probably not as they seem I
mean that you know you've got this sort
of imbalance in the economy where
inflation is built on a very firm
foundation because we see made it home
inflation basically service inflation
very strong and then we have the past
three effects of weaker sterling pushing
up and of course imported food prices
and when you look at the producer price
figures also out today I mean
double-digit input inflation that is
going to work its way through the supply
chain pipeline and when you look at
consumer however remarkable strength but
this strength build on consumers running
down savings maxing out the credit cards
it can't last forever particularly if
prices are pushing down on disposable
incomes so Mark Carney's said previously
the governor of the Bank of England that
he's prepared to look through temporary
inflation effects but at what point does
the bank starter get seriously worried
that inflation is becoming baked in and
they have to move on interest rates yes
there's a sense that the bank villain is
looking at inflation as collateral
damage they're prepared to look through
the short term rise in inflation and
likely deep overshoot having ass
inflation top three percent by the end
of this year because they're concerned
about the fragility of the underlying
growth in in consumer spending and
they're worried that should anything
change in consumer conditions as price
rises tend to a row purchasing power
tend to squeeze down on real wages or
should we see some volatility in Europe
because of the forthcoming French
election so anything else that's coming
through in the pipeline that could knock
down they could create a steep fall in
inflation as the lasting in the banker
wants at a time when they've maxed out
their tools interest rates at record
lows the balance sheet is as strong as
they could get it before inflation
started rising so this is a very
difficult plans I talked about the
position of individual retailers and
Andrew who do you think is most
vulnerable here to these kind of
conditions I think the clothing
retailers have been having a really
difficult time they should get some
relief from the hot weather the
supermarkets are vulnerable i think
Sainsbury's is particularly vulnerable
they've just thought our
awesome oh this has been going quite
well let's think I cut well but that's
on the sales lime we don't know what's
happening to the margin the majority of
the products will be imported that's
going to be quite a difficult situation
Tesco's got a lot riding on this trading
period they've got results tomorrow
they're trying to do this big merger
with Booker trying to convince investors
so they will really want their trade to
be going in the right direction so
really very nervous time all in on the
high street there exactly